you even won the fan vote like the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame says Hey fans you
get a vote and it was the first time
that the artist who won the fan boat was
kept out of the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame first of all I was phoning
furiously I was Voting if you're
um
a whole rack of phones I don't know if
it's important to you or not but I find
it kind of [__] insulting I mean you
need to come up if there's any outcome
that could arguably be better than
actually getting into the heart the the
whole not not to say there's anything
better than getting into the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame but if there was
anything better than getting into the
all the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame it
would be if the fans overwhelmingly
voted for you to get in and then you
still weren't letting
that's a good City
you're saying in other words it was like
Susan Lucci who never won a Daytime Emmy
and then it became even bigger yeah I'm
essentially parallel if not almost
identical to Susan Lucci absolutely
absolutely they say Dave Matthews Susan
Lucci of the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
have you ever seen them in the same room
together is the often what I hear no no
I'm just saying
foreign